oh recently i watched yesterday in fact
this is good timeline i watched the new
doctor strange movie i am how is it very
mid
actually it's probably one of the most
boring
movies i've watched in a long time
really oh wow okay cause i i heard like
a lot of good things about it i'm sad i
was really excited for it i
um watch it make your own mind up i also
watched it in dolby atmos and i was way
too close to the front and i really
regret it because some of that [ __ ]
sound effects there's this one sound
effect in the start where like he
summons like a saw and i swear to god it
really punctured my ear this this sore
sound
but yeah no it was weird it was all over
the place the thing that i don't like
about doctor strange um i don't know if
anyone else feels this way
i don't know what the [ __ ] his powers
are like it's just like whatever he
needs to do yeah yeah it's just like
he's like all right he does he does the
circle okay do a circle uh then now i
summon a a monster and now i summon a
boat and it's like
i don't know what the [ __ ] your
abilities are like i i don't know no one
has ever taught and there is never a
scene where he's learning these powers
yeah like individual speakers i've
always just how does this work i've
always just said like he he's his power
is kind of like the metronome move in
pokemon you know where it's just like he
just waggles his fingers and something
happens you know it's like i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on and the entire
movie feels like when you're kids with
you know when you're when you're like
eight years old and you pretend like you
have like a magic fight with your your
childhood friend you're like yeah and i
summoned this oh no i i do this oh i
drew this back that's what the whole
movie felt like it was just it's not
just a jojo fight yeah but like at least
jojo there's some tense to it there's
some intensity yeah this entire fight
was like all right well of course she's
gonna win and then it's just this yeah
there's just so it's just like what what
the [ __ ] is this movie i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on it's so stupid this
entire movie was just like all right now
this i know this
and it's like what is happening yeah i
heard from like like comic book fans
like dr strange is meant to be like one
of the most powerful beings in like the
avengers or whatever right and they've
just like completely nerfed him in the
mcu or something like that um because i
don't have no idea what the [ __ ] his
ability is apart from just like
summoning uh summoning the circle thing
and something the teleport
basically it's just paul right
maybe he's just the poor yeah maybe
maybe maybe the character in the comics
is interesting but like i was so [ __ ]
bored in this movie yeah i was like and
then halfway through there they because
it's the multiverse and then they
introduce other marvel characters from
other marvels and then it's supposed to
be like i guess just comic book boner
moments where i'm just supposed to be
like impressed that
uh they included that scene
from the x-men turned up
i don't give a [ __ ] why is i i'm not
impressed by this like there's just a
moment where like he'll come in and then
the music will play the stereotypical oh
it's a character you're supposed to
[Applause]
and know it's like all right cool and
now and then he's dead and then it's
like all right okay
what is happening dude
is it because like you just haven't
watched many mcu movies i've watched a
lot of them i've watched a lot of them
and this was the only one like i haven't
watched was eternals because i heard it
was complete doo-doo yeah and
uh
captain marvel i didn't watch because i
heard it was really bad yeah this is
probably one of the worst ones i say
you've watched every marvel movie post
end game as well post end game what's
there been just no way home oh there's
been no way home there's been
black widows i've watched black widow
that was god awful
saying she was okay thank you
they've been taking big l's i feel these
movies have been i just feel like they
are still building up
no way home was really good no way home
was [ __ ] but that was because i i i
kind of got what i wanted out of that
yeah i was like yeah i kind of expected
yeah movie and
yeah yeah
i'm sad because like i'm not that hyped
for any new marvel movies coming out and
doctor strange was one of the few i was
actually hyped about i was i've really
hyped about no way home and that meant
that met my expectations
oh um i i just felt that it was like
i you know when you you watch a movie
and i wanted to watch it to give my
thoughts yeah but at the same time i'm
like [ __ ] i don't want to give them
money so they think that i want more of
this right i don't want more of this
right like i'd rather i don't know like
i heard like morbius was really really
bad i hope that's that's the worst
marvel movie of like or anything marvel
related well it's like it's not
marvelous it's um
it's sony
okay that's that's not that's not empty
so it's not exactly mcu yeah yeah
obviously
it's apparently really bad i don't know
i maybe watch it and give me your
thoughts because i'm really torn on it
because there were some moments that i
thought was really interesting and i
thought yeah okay this is good but the
rest of the time i'm like this just felt
like a movie they wanted to make just
because they were like well
i guess we could get benedict
cumberbatch to act himself out three
times and we could that could be fun and
it's just like all right and uh yeah and
i don't know it was just really
long-winded and boring and i i the
moment my popcorn ran out i was kind of
i was kind of like
kind of like i was like that was the
final draw well there's no reason for me
to be here now i went with emily and
dadis and they were just laughing all
the time as well at some of the some of
the dialogue was so bad did they enjoy
it uh they thought it was really bad as
well okay okay so they're really
enjoying like ironically yeah there were
some lines of dialogue that was just
like who wrote this like this was like
completely absurd this is like a
four-year-old wrote here yeah i don't
know maybe viewers maybe i'm wrong maybe
you disagree with me let me know what
you think i haven't looked at any
critical reviews of it so i don't know
what critics are saying but i would give
it it's the 10 out of 10
for me it's a 4 out of ten yeah i was
very is it the worst marvel movie you've
seen no
what's the worst one you've seen
thought two was pretty bad oh that was
pretty good
that just sounds bad from the name yeah
like thought two is pretty boring like
i'm looking forward to the new thor uh
yeah it just seems fun that that's that
seems fun yes four four four four four
yeah
do you have marvel movie fatigue i'm
just like i don't know just make blade
just make blade and make it good
i definitely like i definitely have
marvel movie fatigue in the sense where
i'm just watching it just to like keep
up and there are like i had marvel i had
marvel movie fatigue after like iron man
2. i just feel like they're like
fumbling right now they're like what are
these movies what are they making
what the [ __ ] they're trying to say i
think they're fumbling i just think
once you end with endgame and it's just
like an end of like 10 years of build-up
it's just like well [ __ ] how do you how
do you like how long is it going to take
to build up something that's going to be
as exciting because right now i'm not
even like invested in the characters as
much i was you know [ __ ] iron man or
captain america or like the main
the the main guys in like the previous
generation so it's like who is going to
be
that you know that main guy and i
thought it was going to be doctor
strange and you know i thought that was
a possibility
i don't know like i'm just a resident
sleeper dude that entire
i kind of shut off the first hour i was
like really bored yeah like watching
chiang chi was cool but i'm just like
i'm watching like a ushia movie and then
you have like you're barely relating
this to the mcu somehow whatever i'm not
really like i don't really care about
that you know i made for the cool cool
fights well i was watching um
uh your movie sucks and uh he was doing
his review of all the like films of the
year or the yeah yeah yeah and like
seventy percent of them he was like i
didn't finish it it was [ __ ] right a lot
of people got angry because they were
like oh how can you review a film if you
didn't finish it yeah
but i was like
i mean surely if you can't finish a film
that says that says something more than
anything yeah it's it's like how
critical do you want to be
it's more like yeah you can say you
really didn't [ __ ] like a movie and
not finish it because i've done that
plenty of times with anime you know but
if you want me to like properly critique
it then there's only so much i can
critique without seeing all of it
because i didn't see all of it you know
it's it's a nuanced argument but i think
you should very much be allowed to say
yeah i thought something sucked
and uh because i didn't finish it yeah
yeah exactly i don't know yeah i feel
like
if i was watching that many movies as
well i wouldn't be yeah you got to start
like you know using your time wisely
right like you don't want to waste your
time on something that you think is just
going to be like your opinion is not
going to change on it regardless if you
should